the HMS Vigilant prepares to dive diving
stations diving St it's part of the UK's
nuclear deterrent a submarine Fleet
that's nuclear powerered and nuclear
armed this is home the fuz lane Naval
Base on the shores of G lock in
Northwest Scotland the fate of which
hangs on Thursday's independence vote
they're harming my country I don't want
it I used to that I glowed in the dark
well I hope I don't residents of nearby
helbor have had an uneasy relationship
with their nuclear
neighbor the town's even home to a
permanent protest Camp it's it's not
very often that we have an opportunity
like this to make a decision that has a
meaningful impact on the future of the
nuclear weapons here the uh Community is
divided in this particular Community the
overwhelming majority I think are
definitely for no and there are a number
of reasons for that uh not least of
course the uh the presence of fazlin uh
base in in the community and that has a
huge economic impact fan employs more
than 6 and a half thousand
people if Scotland votes yes this week
one thing's for sure the Navy will have
to find a new home for the nuclear subs
a hes somewhere else on the UK
Shore